do you think I will do a good job yeah
[Laughter]
alright I am with my mom for this video
I am gonna dress my mom in my
generations clothing trend are you
excited yeah how do you describe your
style my style very simple what colors
do you like to wear color and flower but
also sometimes she wears a lot of like
pattern she's a very smart shopper she
says coupons she goes on holiday sales
with my aunts well today we are going to
hmm
oh I thinking offensive there what's
cool is that I've never seen my mom in
these clothes ever before what do you
think our family members will say wow
maybe you are rich yeah so we're gonna
go shop and she's gonna wear the clothes
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
and we're gonna get reactions from all
our family members and all our friends
shall be styling its threw me back to
when I was younger and I was shopping
with my mom shopped for four hours my
mom kept trying to control what I was
choosing for her so I had to separate
her to the other side of this door so I
could shop and comfort and I got to play
with so many different colors and
textures that I've never seen my mom in
covered everything that I wanted I'm so
happy with my choices for her I got this
leather jacket for her I have never seen
her wear leather my whole life leather
just calls out badass which is how I see
my mom this is a power jacket especially
with the gold chain and the purse badass
yet fancy heading out to like a girls
night out ready to beat up some people
at a bar and don't mess with me a jacket
[Applause]
you look before yeah
oh do you mind no one bother me I'll
kick their butt he won me a table very
high not easy for walking I think
jacket Allah button we're about to go
out and see what people think my mom's
used to wearing what one inch heels and
this one's two and a half she and
originally thought it was eight inches
what do you think oh very good today
very nice I think about 35 yeah I like
it look beautiful boobies now she can be
a football doesn't she look like she
could create oh wait
alway be a fun mom this coat I got
because I love the giant collar just
called out fashion something Anna
Wintour would wear super comfy perfect
for a colder day everything is so giant
except the sleeves which shows that it
is meant to be that big when you walk
into someone's house they're like can I
have your coat and you're like yeah I
got a coat like the CEO of like a
fortune 500 company I love the different
angles of the Bata sharp corners fashion
week type code where does it fit
very very nice beautiful I'm I got
something my son's bio my profession I
think it looks better than what she used
to wear really matter outfit very older
Asian lady patterns that you can find at
the vid amis market Blair style yeah I
chose this because it's pink loose so
it's comfortable the buttons on the side
add a little bit of flare cute flats
also Millenial pink super girly but
age-appropriate pants a slender I like
that you could see the buttons on the
pant with the top tucked in you look
like you're about to go to town have a
Cosmo even though she doesn't drink
maybe she'll have some tea she's gonna
make all the ladies in the neighborhood
jealous
the color matches are elected
like a show about your grandma Jo
no big honestly do you want her to
continue this look the style I chose
this outfit because I love the poofy
arms it looks very Gaga s the bows are
very cool and youthful and feminine I
love the contrast between the white and
black and hunch of red a purse is super
classy I love the gold chains hats are
super slimming with the boots the boots
are super hip I like that the gold
buckle matches the gold chain of the
purse this whole look screams youth
fashion extravaganza ready to go dancing
or shopping at some fancy store it's a
very versatile look I think it's
age-appropriate yeah hella youthful she
looks very tall dance of style and I
like the frills with the party young oh
yeah I don't look
like it looks like a white bag maybe I
can fly I chose this outfit because I
wanted a comfy casual look chill relax
something around the house it's a thin
coat so that can be tossed on whenever
she wants like a soft little blanket
there's a lot of textures going on
studded letters on the sweater
it says gray because this outfit is all
gray yet it stands out love the boots
like my mom likes to go on walks oh this
is perfect for that winter cool chill
weather modern with a touch of comfort
hip free relaxed all these words come to
mind this is perfect for sitting around
watching venom use television Washington
Paris by night going to visit relatives
nowhere no going cold go I'll be popping
I wear the sea where the we are go to
Dina my grandson will say Oh to the
grandma Betty parson I went along home
you like it see I don't know nice low
fuzzy look at this comfy outfit this is
like we're going shopping on a winter's
day drinking a Starbucks yeah I feel
comfortable what was your favorite
outfit no penguin no Matador it cool
which one would you wear again nobody
went because the weather it going cold
very comfortable yeah my favorite outfit
for her was definitely the white poofy
one that one was very classy and special
and unique when you see it far away
you're like whoa what's so nice thank
you I will wear that often where I think
jacket then leather jacket John I think
you're strong that's why it fits very
well well I had such a good experience
I'm so glad I got to finally see my mom
in different types of clothes I've
always like wondered about like well
what'd she look like and now I got to
see it thank you for doing it thank you
the company
about time I wish somebody what video
clip saying oh the lady pity or the lady
fani I thank you so much
[Music]
all right yes Obama bye-bye